Einheitlich wie bei den Katologen. Wenn man sich den nationalen Leitlinien vornimmt und liest, dann heißt es, man muss es individuell immer betrachten.
Wenn Sie jetzt in der Notaufnahme sind und da kommt ein Patient klar, was machen Sie? Sie gucken als erst mal den Nüchternzucker,
den akuten Zuckerwert, ist der bei 150 oder ist der bei 400 oder 500 oder 600?
Wenn natürlich jemand ein HB1C von über 10 hat,
dann kann sich ich wiederhole nochmal, Sie sind in der Notaufnahme und der Patient kommt mit welchen Beschwerden, mit Übelkeit oder Unwohlsein.
Das heißt, Sie wissen, er ist Diabetiker. Also das erste ist, Sie schauen natürlich sofort nach dem Blutzucker,
der Blutzucker, den Nüchternzucker oder den akuten Zuckerwert, ist der jetzt bei 150 oder ist er bei 400 oder 500 oder noch mehr?
Das ist das erste. Sie messen als erst mal den Blutzucker. Wahrscheinlich wollte er eine ganz einfache Antwort wissen.
Also in den Prüfungen ist es meistens so, dass man erst mal etwas ganz einfaches fragt, aber man denkt komplex.
Ich denke, wir wollten wissen, welche Schritte machen Sie, was wollen Sie wissen.
Das heißt, erst mal Blutzucker und dann natürlich auch die Blutgase.
Ist er sauer? Wie ist die Raustrucksättigung?
Denn davon wird man abhängig machen, ob er a, auf die Intensivstation kommt.
Ich sitze ein Patient und hatte jetzt bei Ihnen in der Notaufnahme einen Zuckerwert von 420.
Was machen Sie? Sie können nicht sagen, gehen nach Hause, mit Formid absetzen und fangen irgendwann mal mit Insulin an.
Der muss auf die Intensivstation in dem Moment, weil er kommt halt in die Acidosi rein.
Sie brauchen als zweites die Blutgase. Wie ist sein aktueller Zustand?
Denn man gibt Insulin, senkt das Insulin, aber das muss man kontrolliert dann machen.
Die Gase, Blutzucker und wenn dann der Zucker runtergeht auf 200, dann beginnt man auch, gegen zu regulieren mit Glucose.
Insulin und Glucose und die Graßituation auszugleichen, also die Blutgase und die Sauererverhältnisse.
Wahrscheinlich wollte er das wissen. Sie müssen als erstes natürlich erstmal den Blutzucker bestimmen.
Wenn es jetzt ein Patient wäre, also das zum ersten. Also wenn der Blutzucker hoch ist, Intensivstation.
Wenn der jetzt ein Blutzucker von 170 hat, normale Blutgase, also nicht sauer, keine Lackdacidosi,
dann können Sie sagen, okay, wir schauen, ob wir eine ambulante Therapie machen.
Also den Patienten wieder nach Hause schicken und dann eine Empfehlung geben, dass er mit Formin und vielleicht noch Insulin und andere Sachen nimmt.
Ich denke, das wäre der wichtigste Punkt in der Notaufnahme zu entscheiden. Bleibt er in Kreisenhaus oder kann ich ihn nach Hause schicken?
Denke auch, ja.
Sollen wir auch?
Sie hätten die Nachfragen müssen, wie ist sein Aktor der Zucker im Moment?
Das heißt, Ihre erste Aufgabe ist erstmal den Zucker zu bestimmen.
Klar, aussaatzt, denkt man ein bisschen anders, aber sie sind in der Notaufnahme.
Das heißt, dann muss man in der Notaufnahme gehört. Es geht ja relativ schnell.
Die meisten Notaufnahmen haben ein kleines Gerät, ein Urlebchen, das am besten von mir aus auch aus dem venüsen Blut.
Die Blutgase beim Diabetiker.
Um zu schauen, hat er eine Acidosi oder nicht?
Ich meine, als erfahrener Arzt sehen Sie natürlich, wenn ein Diabetiker eine Acidosi hat, dann hat er auch eine entsprechende Atmung.
Ja, ja.
Der Atemricht, er ist langsam, er hat blaue Lippen, er ist verlangsamt, er ist ein bisschen desorientiert.
Immer von den Augen.
Ja, das sind sehr fortgeschritten natürlich, klar.
Da können Sie klinisch schon sagen, er ist im Diabetischen Gummazzack hoch, Intensivstation, der muss jetzt intensiv behandelt werden.
Ganz klar, wenn es aber noch nicht so weit ist, immer als erstes Zuckerwärtskontrolle und die Blutgase.
In der Hausarztpraxis hat man natürlich immer das Gerät für eine Blutgasanalyse, aber im Krankenhaus eigentlich immer.
Ansonsten klar, in der Hausarztpraxis, der Api des Diabetes ist sehr weit.
Ja, zum Beispiel denken wir, die Glucoswerte ist 30.
Welche Flüssigkeit sollen wir...
Standszucker ist bei 30 Millikamprodesiliter und da ist man schon fast in Koma.
Normalerweise ein Diabetiker, der Medikamente nimmt, bekommt ja schon...
Entschuldigung.
Hypo-Glypemie und Kalbschweißigelk.
Ich möchte 300 sagen.
Nein, ich möchte 300 sagen.
Was sollen wir als Flüssigkeit durchführen?
Bei 300, das ist so eine Grenze.
Ich würde das abhängig machen von dem Blutgasen.
Wie lange er schon Diabetes hat und wie die Klinik des Patienten ist.
Ich habe auch Patienten bei der Medepraxis, die fast 300 hatten, auch wieder nach Hause geschickt.
Wenn du zu Hause bist, dann nimmst du noch mal vier Einheiten insulin oder von seinem Langzeiten insulin,
noch mal fünf Einheiten mehr und trinken, trinken mehr so ein bisschen.
Das muss man individuell entscheiden, also das kann man glaube ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Insulin heißt Krystallisirinsulin, ja?
Es gibt unterschiedliche Insulin, wie gesagt.
Es gibt auch diese Patienten.
Es gibt alte Insulin, es ist humaninsulin oder humaninsulin.
Es ist klassische Insulin, ganz klar.
Aber das muss man halt sehr streng kontrolliert unter Staatssinnung, bitte.